Alors c'est parti pour l'ouverture des cadeaux,
On commence par l'arbre à chat, es-tu content ?
Yes.
Ah !
Faut tout monter soi-même. Bah, c'est parti !
3, 2, 1...
Yes. Merlin !
Il y a un petit cadeau pour toi.
Les chats ont vraiment une logique implacable.
(Voix robotique) J'adore ce carton.
Oh, le petit tunnel ! Ouiiii, bravo !
Il veut me taper !
Oh la petite saucisse !
Hoooooooooo.
Let's go !
*Musique de combat*
Une petite hutte pour chats.
Encore un truc bien chiant à monter.
Oh ça paraît pas trop compliqué en fait.
Ça par contre, c'est le début des embrouilles.
Gé-nial.
C'est parti pour l'atelier "pliage".
Et le tipi est prêt !
Énorme tipi en carton !
Oh, c'est un succès !
Énorme succès du tipi.
Et bah, t'es bien dedans là.
Comment il va ? Est-ce qu'il prend du plaisir ?
Alors ça, c'est un petit vêtement spécial euh... "Maître-Chat" on va dire.
Donc, collection automne-hiver.
Avec des petits pompons.
Attends, je vais directement le mettre.
'Tain je vais devoir ôter mon petit pull poisson, je suis dégoûté.
Tu pourras flouter cette zone ou pas ?
Attention, c'est parti
Normalement, ça c'est une petite sacoche pour le transporter...
...comme un kangourou, tu vois.
C'est le moment, de tester.
Tu vas vivre une expérience, mon pote, t'imagines même pas.
Putain, c'est trop mignon de ouf !
Oh, un petit choux !
Voilà !
Ouais, on se voit mercredi ou pas ?
On se fait un petit apéro ?
Ouais, on fait un truc, on...on boit du Schweppes.
Putain mais je vais le porter tous les jours, c'est sûr.
FAUX !
Objet suivant ! Ça c'est une sorte de petit fromage jouet avec des souris qui sortent.
C'est un peu la PS4 des chats.
'Tain pour un humain, c'est ultra moyen quoi.
Il réagit, mais immédiatement quoi.
Bon voilà hein, c'est le même truc pendant 30 ans.
Il y a pas un truc qui va changer tout d'un coup, c'est un transformer !
Alors ça, devinez ce que c'est.
C'est la mer noire ?
Eh bien, c'est une brosse à chat, en forme de langue de chat.
Oui cet objet est inutile !
C'est écrit, "Lick your cat"
Ça veut dire "Lèches ton chat"
Merlin !
Tu veux que je te lèches le uc ?
Et c'est parti !
Tu n'aimes pas, hein ?
Il n'aime vraiment pas du tout, ça.
Bon, on va essayer sans le lécher.
Ahhhh.
Donc cet objet à été validé à 8%.
Next !
Ce sont des sacs de transport pour chats...astronautes.
Donc, celui-ci est un peu plus ambiance "Jules Verne"
Ou 50 nuances de Grey.
Et c'est là que tu mets le petit hublot où le chat met sa tête qui dépasse.
Ok, ok !
Premier sac monté, au bout de 8 ans.
Je tiens à préciser qu'aucun de ses objets est un placement de produit, c'est que des petits kiffes.
Des petits achats coup de coeur.
Sac n°2, monté !
Lequel tu préfères ?
Oh, oh bah ! Oh, finalement le vert.
Allez, c'est parti pour le vert.
Je sens que ça va clairement être une catastrophe.
Et contre toute attente, ce chat est en kiffe totale du sac.
C'est incroyable, il est totalement en kiffe absolu.
Ah ! Là il se dit, "peut-être y a une arnaque" !
En effet, y avait bien une arnaque.
Je me suis fait piégé.
Est-ce qu'on peut mettre aussi son ordinateur, sa trousse et tout dedans quoi ?
Genre, le mec, il a 30 ans, il a une trousse quoi.
Allez, je le mets sur le dos et je vais au travail.
Ah, bah non, j'ai pas de travail, yes.
Bon je vous laisse, bonne soirée hein.
*sifflements*
Allez, on va le libérer le pauvre, ça n'a durer que 5 minutes.
C'est bon, t'as tenu le coup.
Ouiiiiiiiiii.
Je suis avec des potos qu'on a contacté, sur Internet...
...qui fabriquent des sortes de circuits pour chats...
...des trucs pour les chats !
Bon, ça paraît un peu chelou comme ça, mais ça va rendre, un truc de ouf !
Bah, on va les laisser installer hein, parce que c'est un vrai taf. Ça c'est pas un truc que je peux faire.
Donc je vais faire semblant de vous aider, parce que moi, je suis très nul en...bricolage.
Allez les gars, on s'active un petit peu !
Plus rapide s'il vous plaît !
(Caméraman) Bon, je crois que ça va être un peu trop long.
J'avoues, c'est 100 fois plus gros que ce que j'imaginais mais...
...on a combien de vies en fait ?
Il y a carrément une télécommande pour changer la couleur...
...euh...du logo "M" ! Comme Merlin !
Le rouge, c'est genre il est occupé.
Et le vert il est dispo !
(Caméraman) Ha ha ! C'est trop stylé.
C'est comme un taxi quoi.
*Thème d'Indiana Jones*
*untro*